I imagine a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired feel safe wherever they
are and end the day fulfilled by the
work that they do now I know this is an
ideal and I'm often accused of being a
crazy idealist and sometimes I think
that of myself until I met Bob Chapman
he has a company barry-wehmiller that
actually does the things that I talk
about he's built a remarkable culture
and so I can no longer be accused of
being a crazy idealist if what I imagine
exists in reality I've known Bob for a
bunch of years and he's become a close
friend and so it was really exciting for
me to call him up and hear what he has
to say about leadership and what it
takes to build a great company this is a
bit of optimism Bob Chapman I can't tell
you what an absolute joy it is for me to
sit down and talk to you you and I met
10 years ago I received a letter from
you that you were telling me that you'd
saw my TED talk and that you'd built a
company that looks like what I was
talking about so I said let's meet for
lunch and we met for lunch for an hour
and we got along so well that we both
cleared our calendars for the rest the
afternoon and here we are 10 years later
yeah I think we both walked in with no
expectations you just tolerated meeting
with me because you were very busy and I
just went because intellectually it
seemed kind of Internet I had no
expectation that's what it was and you
said I hear you I love it but I honestly
don't believe it you didn't believe what
I said you and remember Simon you were
the first external person that ever came
in to look at our culture and so you
opened the door of our culture to the
world and and I remember we went around
the country and you said go ahead and
walk around and talk to anybody you want
to ask them any question you like and
you didn't go with me and what I saw I
was blown away I was I saw this this
corporate culture where people cared
about each other there was love in the
air and I heard the stories of how they
were treated at work and how they took
care of each other it was just
mind-blowing yeah
the thing that I love about your company
barry-wehmiller is you're a
manufacturing company good old-fashioned
America
Manufacturing you make large machines
the kinds of machines like when Kimberly
Clark for example needs a big machine to
make toilet paper your company makes
that machine and then sells it to
industry and so it's not a traditionally
glamorous business people think that you
know great cultures exist in Silicon
Valley where you have you know organic
cafeterias and flat-screen TVs
everywhere and when I asked you what do
you do you say we build great people to
do extraordinary things and it's your
culture that you've committed to
building which then produces great
product great customer service great
everything else but I love how you're so
focused on your people it's so special
and it's proof that you don't need a
glamorous industry and you don't need
big advertising or all this crazy stuff
to build a remarkable remarkable place
to go to work right and the thing that I
saw when I came to Phillips in Green Bay
was I saw perhaps the best example of
the the workplace that I imagined
remember that was the outcome but that
wasn't our intent our intent
originally awakened by the experiences I
had was we wanted to send people home
feeling valued fulfilled we used the
word fulfilled
I didn't realize though the one when we
set that goal of sending people home
fulfilled that they would in turn treat
those around them the way they were
being treated so we found that caring is
contagious and so you saw something we
didn't see and our intent was not to
create that it was just to send people
home feeling cared for so they could be
good stewards at home and again
astounding to me was we realized in this
journey after you open the door to this
the way we treat people at work
profoundly affects the way they go home
and treat people in their span of care
so if we're sending 88% of the people in
this world home not feeling valued what
is the family unit like of children
raised with parents who feel they work
in an organization doesn't care about
them so again when we teach people how
to be leaders ninety-five percent of
feedback is our leadership model affects
their family it's so true when washing
University organizational development
professors came out to interview me as
few years back they sat down because
they'd heard about our culture and we
talked for probably an hour and a half
at the end these professors looked at me
and said you know you're the first CEO
I've ever taught
- that never talked about their product
in the entire interview I said we've
been talking about her product for the
last hour and a half our product is our
people okay we build great people and I
said that is the key we live in a
society you know where we have TGIF
thank God it is Friday I imagine a
society where we have TGIM thank
goodness this Monday we get back in a
place where I feel valued I get to
contribute my gifts I get to play the
game of business with people again
number one source of happiness for the
world is meaningful work in a company
that you feel respected so we have
discovered with your help that business
could be the most powerful force of good
in the world if they simply had the
skill and the courage to care for the
people they have the privilege of
leading that could be a powerful force
of healing in this country and I think
such a powerful statement for some of
the things that we're seeing happening
in the world today right the thing I
wanted to talk to you about was loyalty
you know I have deep loyalty to you this
is a very close 10-year relationship
we've had I consider you a close friend
and mentor but loyalty is it seems to be
you know we don't see much loyalty these
days in the workplace and if people
aren't loyal to their companies like
they used to the companies are
definitely not loyal to their people
there seems to be this disguise of
loyalty first of all is that a problem
is loyalty important I wouldn't use the
word loyalty Simon I would use the word
trust and respect because you know you
have what's called the circle of safety
did you talk about that I learned people
used to feel safe in that circle and
people as you have said don't feel safe
at work they feel used for an economic
goal not human goal since the Industrial
Revolution business thought it was sole
purpose was to create economic values to
mass production new technology etc and
we had decades of that but we never
learned to do it for the right reasons -
which is human dignity yeah you know
Simon I learned something in the last
six months
a gentleman in Wisconsin who's a
football coach read my book wrote to me
to meet with him is named Steve Jones
the winningest football coach in the
history of Wisconsin won 72 games in the
borough five out of six state
championships they wanted to talk and in
the course
I said them how do you define winning in
sports with your team you said we don't
define winning we talk about playing
your position best for your colleagues
go out and play your position well and
let the outcome be the outcome they
never talked about winning we actually
had this coach Steve Jones do a video of
him talking to his kids about how he
defines playing your position well for
your colleagues and we use that in our
leadership meeting because rather than
just saying you to make your bonus to
make your goal you know you all need to
do this we try to bring that same sense
we're doing it for each other not just
for me you're not doing it for your own
career planning your position well as
quarterback are in you're doing it for
your colleagues you're playing your
position well for the benefit of the
whole organization when we look at
companies if we look at just the
self-interest so you know be a good
accountant be a good salesperson
you'll have a good career you make good
money it's much more inspiring to go do
it for everybody else so part of the
scope of 19 cut down we say that every
team member was at home remember your
position is not just your as your role
is in the interest of everybody else if
we all play our position well we will
get through this together so that was a
big learning because you know I don't
like winners and losers and sports I
remember it using your skill we're
helping to schools try and incorporate
their why into athletics and a coach
came up to me and I said well how was
your season she said well we lost in the
semi-finals I said I'm just curious why
did you define your season as you lost
in the semi-finals
why wouldn't you have said we had an
incredible team and we made it all the
way to the semi-finals because in
society we have winners and losers were
divided by issues not United by purpose
and so remember Simon that statement
that's on our wall in our building that
says we imagine a society this year your
words we imagine a society where people
think of others first I'll omit the fact
enough and say that if you go to the
bookshop there's an entire section
called self-help but there's no section
called help others yeah because you know
it requires work yeah these things you
know even though it's innate in all of
us selfishness is innate and all in all
of aspis or selflessness innate on all
of us and we can practice these skills
it's like anything else it's like a
muscle you build it the thing that I
find fascinating also is
you weren't always like this no this has
been your own personal journey as well
and so I think a lot of people think
that people either are this way or not
this way but you're such a great example
of any leader can change which is what
makes me optimistic which is everyone
can change the way they lead to create
this world in which everyone matters was
there one event that was a catalyst or
was it like a slow steady thing that
your conversion happened 1997 was the
first event when I had bought this
company and I watched people playing the
game March Madness in the cafeteria and
they were having fun talking about which
team won whether they won five dollars
or ten dollars in the pool they're
having fun the closer they got to eight
o'clock you could just see the fun go
out of your body now I didn't realize it
at the time but what was going on inside
of my mind my heart was why can't
business be fun why do we call it work
the word of people express their gift so
I started creating these games as you
know which was the very beginning that
was the first step I created games for
when people won the company won and they
won so I aligned value creation to fun
and we saw had profound changes in
performance which was not my goal my
goal was just so they have fun but we
saw this profound change in performance
does that was the first thing so I said
why can't business be fun then I
realized that the church service that
the faith which tries to create people
of meaning and purpose they only have
people in a religion normally for one
hour a week at most and we have people
in business for 40 hours a week we are
40 times more powerful to impact
people's lives than our faiths and so I
realized that business could be the most
powerful force for good and then the
culmination was where I realized that
all 12,000 people that work for us
around the world were not engineers
architects machinists assemblers
shipping clerks there were somebody's
precious child that have been placed in
our care and that's when I brought my
skills that you talk about all the time
and how parenting and leadership is
identical I realized that when you look
at people not as a function for your
success
I need that engineer to design a machine
I need that accountant get financial
orders but when you reverse and you say
that life has been placed in my care and
the way I treat that person is going to
profoundly affect their health and the
way
they go home and treat their family
members I was profoundly changed in the
expression as you know there's most
known for is everybody is somebody's
precious child and that was the
culmination of those three of
experiences you and I believe that
leadership is just like parenting where
people say this all the time well I
didn't get to choose my team well you
didn't get to choose your children you
still love them what in your experience
like what have you personally changed in
the way you used to lead versus the way
you lead now when you started to see all
of your employees as someone's precious
child well first of all you have to go
back to Cynthia and I have six kids and
back in the 70s with six kids in my care
I didn't know how to be a good parent
and so if we took classes aren't
parenting and we started yells to young
presidents organization others too how
can I be a good steward of these
precious lives have been blessed upon us
and through the 70s and 80s as I
continued learning about parenting and I
was embracing leadership all of a sudden
one day I realized parenting and
leadership is identical what's parenting
the stewardship of those precious lives
are coming to our lives through births
adoption or second marriage so we all
take very seriously what is leadership
the stewardship of those precious lives
the people that walk in our building all
over the world simply wanting to know
that who they are and what they do
matters which is the same as parenting
so then we started getting ideas like we
know Simon if you don't compliment a
child five times more than you might
suggest things they do better that you
were gonna have an oppressed child you
were gonna be hurting that child because
they're not going to be able to receive
the constructive advice if they don't
feel valued so that was the first thing
recognition and celebration catching
people doing things right all those are
attributes everything in our leadership
model comes from parenting because it's
identical what do you want for your kids
you want them to be who they're intended
to be and feeling good about whatever
that is what do you want for your 12,000
people you wanted to be who they're
intended to be and feeling good about
this so they can go home and be good
stewards of kids remember Simon we have
a society that is based upon money
monetary value and so we create an
education system that gives you
technical skills so you can get a good
job get out of high school with a good
grade get into
right College with good grades so you
can get a good job it's all about the
end result a good job with good pay
isn't that what you won't want for your
kids and what we know for a fact is we
don't give them human skills we give
them technical skills because the market
wants so our educational system has
become a skills factory not a human
factory where we prepare people to live
lives the meaning purpose so until our
schools start embracing the
responsibility for human skills like
empathetic listening recognition
celebration seeing people for their
beauty until our schools embrace the
whole child not just the mind of the
child but the whole child you and I are
gonna have a full career trying to help
people find the true north the way that
we are called to lead right before the
pandemic we had the lowest employment in
50 years we're at peace in the world
people could change job make good money
and we had not we had an epidemic of
anguish this university presidents
Harvard he said are told me that
incoming students to our universities
have the highest level of depression and
anxiety ever and they don't know what to
do about why we have full employment we
have economic gains where people because
people don't feel valued they feel used
for somebody else's success I have
conversations with leaders about this
that they criticize this young
generation when they start work that
they're not loyal they're not engaged
they'll leave in six months or a year
and we don't want invest too much in
them because they don't stick around and
I try and explain that during the 80s
and 90s we saw this rise of selfishness
this rise of finite thinking we're
planning became shorter and shorter term
goals became shorter and shorter term we
started to use people's livelihoods to
balance the books that even though we
were profitable we weren't profitable
enough so we just had a bunch of layoffs
so he could meet our arbitrary
projections that all of these things
started to really take hold and become
the normal way of doing business in the
80s and 90s and definitely worth
solidified in the 2000s and so this
young generation that was born in those
years watched their parents lose their
jobs through no fault of their own that
it wasn't a meritocracy their parents
worked hard and cared about the company
nothing that they did the company missed
their arbitrary projections their
parents were laid off and this is what
they saw they saw companies giving their
parents
no care and no loyalty and so they grew
up being very very cynical of leadership
and business rightfully so I would add
and so if leaders want their young
people to be loyal and stick around and
care about the company and be engaged
not just be looking for the next job
well then to your point show them a
little love show them a little care let
them know that they matter and they'll
stay for a long time
companies like yours don't have a
problem with young people leaving in six
months or a year people who join your
organization want to stay regardless of
their age remember I said to Dean of a
major Business School I said what is
your vision for the two years you have
these men and women in your care in the
MBA program he said we don't have
visions
we have beliefs that are on the wall and
I said well if you don't have a vision
how do you know what to teach and he
said we teach what the market wants I
said to the Dean I said you know you're
just like me you're in the manufacturing
business you did raw material the best
raw material you can which is young men
and women you process them through a
system and then you sell them to the
market and if you get a good price for
these kids you must be doing a good job
so we are clearly self-destructing as a
society in chasing of economic value
which we assume is happiness beyond a
level of substance there's no
relationship between money and happiness
so okay so professor Chapman yes in the
universities and MBA programs they're
teaching the wrong skills and you assert
that one of the reasons that leaders
will people in leadership positions come
in and lead this way managed this way is
because that's what they're taught
that's all they know can you share a
specific example let's teach a new skill
here like share with me something that
you do in your company that is the
opposite and can have even a more
powerful effect in the business the
single most important thing we have
learned in our company is we need to
teach people to listen to each other
which is the key to caring I always
thought when you cared for somebody you
went over and talked to them it turns
out when you care for somebody you go
over to listen to them with empathy
which is a teachable skill and when we
teach that in our business it profoundly
changes people's relationship when they
feel valued and the key is to listen and
to recognize good behavior so I would
say to you that our universities do not
teach
our schools do not teach this and when
you ask them they say we teach a debate
class we teach speech class critical
thinking they teach talking exactly
right because that's what we value yeah
remember biliary biliary is really
Emmure the author of getting to yes
Darvin job billiary said what if we had
a world where a highly valued attribute
of anybody is to be a good listener not
a good talker not a good talker but a
good listener
what if our schools started giving young
kids basic skills to go through life
when they graduate if they are prepared
to care because we have a society build
upon individual success not collective
success so Bob how do you teach
listening so do you have listening
classes in your company we now teach it
around the world in four or five
different languages is it mandatory or
voluntary it is voluntary but we have
people lined up to take the class all
over the world and again when we teach
people to listen at work to be better
leaders they don't tell us I ran a
better accounting department a better
sales department they say to us my
marriage has never been better and my
teenage daughters are talking to me so
what does it take to be a better
listener it's a skill right so what are
some of the specific things that are
taught in the class on how I can become
a better listener one is to be fully
present because usually you're thinking
about your answer and what you're going
to respond instead of listening so it's
a skill to learn to be fully present to
actually listen to what your the person
is trying to say that's going on the
second is confrontation because a lot of
people are hurting other people but they
don't know it and people are reluctant
to say the way you're treating me is
hurting me and so we teach effective
confrontation which allows people say I
need you to help me Simon
and so you're asking helpless said of
criticize so I would say those are the
two think being fully present
I mean fully present doesn't mean
sitting there it means in body language
and words that you can draw out and
people feel that you're listening to
them not judging them not asking for an
answer and the second thing is clearly
equally important how do you let people
know that they could help you and in
something that is hurting you and that's
called confrontation skills those are
the two biggest feedbacks we get you let
me take your class in it it was very
powerful and
here's what I learned when I left the
class I learned that I am a really
really good listener to people who I
will never see again for the rest of my
life who I meet once and with the people
who I care about in love were close to
me and I see and talk to all the time
abominable and it has profoundly changed
the quality of my relationships I have
to tell you that class well remember
billiary who is world peace negotiator
at Harvard he flew up and took a walk
with me up in Aspen after he learned in
this class because he then gave a TED
talk a TEDx talk out in California
aren't listening
what billiary said in this time we had
together that he realizes as a world
peace negotiator he's been involved in
global peace talks for 30 years he now
realizes that's exactly what they are
they're global peace talks the reason we
have the issues we have in the world in
our governments in our political system
and our family is because we talk to
each other but we don't know how to
listen to each other and he said the
reason we have conflict and all these
environments is because we don't know
how to listen we have to talk and if you
look at our education system we do not
teach empathetic listening it's so true
I mean bill says this bill says we have
talk shows but listen shows we have
peace talks I got peace listens yeah and
at school we're teaching speech and
debate but we don't teach listening
skills and isn't that part of the reason
why black lives matter is bubbling up
right now is there's an entire
proportion of our country a proportion
of our country heard right that doesn't
feel seen that doesn't feel understood
and isn't that what every human being on
the planet
fundamentally once regardless of who we
are what our policies are every one of
us wants to feel seen feel heard and
feel understood right and doing those
three things you feel cared for yeah it
is fundamentally Simon it is hard to
care for others if you don't feel cared
for yourself
and the key to P uncared-for is to be
heard to be listened to and remember the
reason that we treat those closer to us
yes we already know what they're gonna
say right the new person uses walk up do
you don't know them so you're more
interested in them because you don't
know them the person you know well that
you talked about maybe not listening as
well to you know what they're gonna say
you know I think so you don't really
to listen to so it is a skill we teach
and it is the most powerful healing
force in the world because right now we
are divided by issues not united by
humanity and that is the key and so how
can we see the kind of leadership that
we want and imagine now in middle
management so that we have the right
leaders who will replace them at the
right time yeah
so remember Simon you use that word that
I hate which is management yeah I have
come to the conclusion that management
means in our society the manipulation of
others for your success leadership means
the stewardship of lives entrusted to
you to genuinely care for the people you
have the privilege of leading with
courage okay it takes courage to care
because we have a society where we use
people for science that assess instead
of caring and financial success is the
outcome and the other thing I want to
make sure you remember is the old
expression you need to get the right
people on the bus I think you need a
safe bus which is a business model that
is resilient and robust to get through
the economic times and then you need
drivers who know how to drive safely and
where they're going and those are your
leaders and so we need to change the
language of business for management
bosses and supervisors to coaches
mentors and leaders we need people to
see themselves as a coach mentor leader
not as a manipulator of people for
financial success so the language you
use in business we fire people that came
from the French firing squad we have in
human terms to describe what needs to be
human organizations and until we change
the language it's hard to change the
behavior and even if we change the
language we need to teach what it means
to care as opposed to use and sometimes
it comes to a point where someone is a
bad fit in the culture and instead of
quote unquote firing them after lots of
coaching and trying to help that you
recognize that they're not happy because
if you're not happy they're not happy as
well and the goal is to help them find a
job where they will be happy and it can
be a productive thing where you can help
them find a new job as opposed to just
saying you're no good you knew would
have to destroy someone selfs confidence
on the way-out
assignment in every speech I get within
the first three questions which is what
you touched on is what do you do about
the people that don't get it okay and I
said you know what my answer that is
treat everybody as somebody's precious
child as you would want your child
treated and they say that would be
different I say
why is it different that somebody's
child you're treating that way so my
standard of care is expect no less of
your behavior with somebody else's child
it would you expect of your own in
parenting Simon it's called hard love
okay
parenting is not giving your kids
everything they want parenting is giving
your kids everything they need okay so
they can develop the skills to go out
into the world and live meaningful and
purposeful lives that is exactly the
same is leadership is giving people the
skills they need to pursue their career
to be who they're intended to be can
appreciate it for whatever that is so
clearly in terms of the people that may
not fit how do you address them with
dignity and let it be a learning
experience so that they can move on and
be empathetic and treat them as you
would want your son or daughter treated
if they didn't work out in the job -
amen can you give another example of
something you do inside your company for
your people that makes them feel cared
for yes I mentioned it earlier but I
want to just amplify it one of the again
from parenting we learned that you need
to spend more five times more time
complement we have a whole program in
our company called recognition and
celebration how do you let people know
in a thoughtful appropriate timely way
proportional way that what they did
matters and so we teach people how to
recognize people and we do it Simon in a
very unique way you know we in most
cases we give a car to describe for a
week as a recognition and we invite the
family quietly secretly to be a part of
the ceremony when their child their
husband or wife is called forward to
receive the keys to the car to drive for
a week the family walks out and becomes
a very emotional experience to see your
wife your husband your your son-in-law
recognized for their goodness nominated
by the peers so we spend a lot of time
and effort looking for the goodness in
an organization's called shining the
light looking for the goodness and
holding up we live in a society Simon
where our people go home every night
turn on media and see the brokenness in
the world every night so what we try to
do is to balance that and look for the
goodness in focus on the goodness and
amplify the goodness not letting that
the brokenness of the world dominate our
culture but the goodness what happens is
it's like throwing a pebble in the water
the ripple effect and it's the most
meaningful experience of their life to
be recognized in front of others for
goodness not top sales not top cost
cutter but for your goodness and that's
the kind of world that we imagine were
people we're looking and recognizing
people and saying thank you
you made a material difference in my
life so recognition and celebration done
thoughtfully proportionally and timely
is a key ingredient what you want to do
is give people a chance to discover
their gifts develop their gifts to share
the gifts and feel appreciated for doing
it it doesn't matter what your business
is it's academic that's just a
particular model car you drive it's
culture that drives profit I think
that's the thing that people fail to
recognize cuts cutting is a short term
solution building a strong culture is
what builds a strong organization and a
strong organization does well I mean
it's 3 out of 4 people in this country
according Gallagher disengaged in what
they're doing how can we possibly play
the game whatever our game of business
is how can we possibly play that fully
when three out of four people are
disengaged in what they're doing
what more statistic do you need to know
if we had a machine tool in our plant
that was only running at 25% of its
capacity of 50 we would address it we
have people in our companies only doing
what they have to do to get by because
they feel no compassion no value they're
not gonna give any more than expected of
them and if another opportunity comes
along they'll move because they don't
feel safe in the company some of the
Millennials that work for us
tell me that their parents say if they
ever quit this job they'll disown them
because they found a place where they
want their child to work where they feel
valued that is our responsibility we
could profoundly change the world if we
simply gave people the skills and the
courage to care for the people they
leave Bob I'm so inspired by you I've
learned so much from you I stand firm in
my commitment to you that I will carry
your torch into the future I will try to
do things that you couldn't have
imagined doing and bring this vision
that we share to life in entirely new
ways and when it is my time I will pass
that torch on to someone else to carry
on our legacy I just love it you know
you and I both imagine a world in which
the vast majority of people wake up
every single morning inspired feel safe
wherever they are and end the day
fulfilled by the work that they do that
is the world we imagine Simon that's the
world we desperately that is the world
at peace and in harmony where people
live and care for each other that is
solution to the issues we face right now
people don't feel cared for they feel
used so there's a lot of people who feel
discriminated against for economic
reasons racial yeah all the reasons
because we just don't know how to care
and so I'm very concerned that we are
self-destructing as a civilization for
economic gain not human gain I love you
Bob Chapman I really do Simon you're
already carrying the torch and you're
carrying it with great pride and you've
shared our message around the world and
you have amplified our message and we
are simply going to try to be the
company that we need to be to be an
example you can do this it is possible
to create human value and economic value
in harmony they are not in harmony and
we should want no less for our 12,000
team members and we want for my six kids
everybody is somebody's precious child
Thank You Simon sonic love you so that
was Bob Chapman he's wonderful and it's
a real joy for me to share his words
with other people if you enjoyed this
and you'd like to hear more please
subscribe wherever you like to hear
podcasts until then take care of
yourself and take care of others
you